we wanted to start with you because I
believe this is your very first time
co-directing on an animated feature so
why was now the right time and also
maybe why did Strange World feel like
the right story for you to take that
leap with uh I think it was a huge
mistake I think this was a terrible time
to do it I think collaborate would die
was awful no it was actually like it was
it was it was it was it was a dream come
true like it's it's uh it's like it was
felt like a natural thing like coming
out of Ryan The Last Dragon uh wanting
um to be involved in the story as much
as I as I already am uh to take that
next step and also be able to uh help
influence like what we're seeing on
screen uh it was it was perfect and you
know Don and I love you know action
adventure stories like the reason why I
got you know even at the studio was the
conversations I had with Don when I
first met him we geeked out over all the
same things comic books football uh and
big adventure films by some of our
favorite creators Indiana Jones Empire
Strikes Back Superman and so that that
that felt like the perfect combination
but basic the perfect movie to be
jumping in to you know do my first
directing job I heard a lot of the right
keywords there I think you're on a good
track and you definitely pick the good
film to make that leap with
um done for you you've got you know
quite a few features as a director under
your belt now so what is something that
you managed to accomplish on strange
world that you know 2011 you making
Winnie the Pooh would look at and go
like oh my God I can't believe I'd be
capable of doing something like that
today
oh that's such a great question
um uh you know I think um
you know it the the fact that the movie
is
um
you know thematically uh solid
and
um you know uh and the animation is
obviously top-notch but I think one of
the things that 2011 me that would be
surprised is how weird the movie is and
how much that was indulged and accepted
by my colleagues and peers and uh
everybody at Disney
um got nothing but like
um you know uh uh nothing but just Good
Vibes and and how weird we wanted to
make this movie you guys seem to have a
little bit of a habit of doing that the
last time the last time we spoke um we
were talking a little bit about the
things that you couldn't believe the
studio let you do on Raya so I guess
I'll follow that up now what is the the
farting Beetle equivalent in strange
world that you just like cannot believe
you got away with we had the whole
sequence that of creatures called poop
pickles uh that was uh where where where
it was just creatures that that that's
almost sole purpose was to be awkward
looking and and make weird sounds uh
which also helped motivate the story and
blah blah blah but the fact that like
the the whole studio came aboard we had
a sequence where we wanted to be super
super weird and it you know we had like
uh you know our viz Dev Department came
in and created these great little poop
pickles we had our viz Dev department or
visual effects Department decide to make
crazy walls that moved and acid lakes
and then you know Don and and Henry
Jackman uh collaborate on a goofy Waltz
to to have this action sequence happen
uh so so it's it's a
it's a fun collaboration like a tiny
child who can't hear you say poop pickle
there are a lot of details and
specifically a lot of different
creatures featured in this movie and I
want to buy and own all of them as as
you reference in the movie I like that
line quite a bit
um is there a particular favorite
creature that you developed whether it's
something that's like front and center
in a frame or maybe something that's in
a background and doesn't get as much
screen time as some of the others hmm
um you know the um I love them all but I
think the the creatures we call the
filter Lopes so they look kind of like
an elk but then they're they have almost
a peacock fan that fans out
um I just think they're really elegant
and beautiful and and originally I think
they were only in one little sequence
sequence and I think everybody fell in
love with them so we just kind of
started peppering them throughout the
movie yeah I always loved those like the
little nubbing things that we have
they're basically like little glowing
balls with feet uh and it's just they're
so simple but yet so just I just love
them every time I get to see a close-up
shot of them I'm just like oh they're
just adorable yeah that's at the top of
my list and I have a feeling the answer
you're going to be hearing quite a bit
is like splat's just perfect because
that's perfect
there so there's a lot of uh really
stunning design elements in your
creatures and also the world overall and
it was making me wonder are there any
new animation tools or techniques being
in being used in strange world that you
know lets you create visuals that at
least to me felt like something I have
never quite seen rendered that way
before
that's a good question um I don't know
if we had any kind of specific uh new
tool set
um I will say I think the the the
artists are at such a high level that no
matter what tool set we have they're
they're going to you know put something
on screen like you've never seen before
um and that was one of the promises of
the movie to me uh is just you know
creating
creating space in a movie to allow these
amazing artists to let their
imaginations run wild and to not put any
barriers on it and just let them go and
and it was such the spirit of the movie
that it was you know like anybody could
think up whatever they wanted and we'll
just figure out how to do it yeah I
think it actually was a huge like kind
of
technological or huge leaps wasn't
technological but actually how we
approached uh making the film uh because
of the environment also being kind of a
character as well as effects being kind
of an environment we had artists now
working together in ways that like you
know animators were talking directly to
uh layout because like one of the ground
planes was a group of little creatures
that they had to run on top of so that
was actually I guess character animation
but it was also an environment and you
had like huge pieces of this visual or
special effects that would end up being
like major piece you know like it was
just the way we were all talking each
other like when even with when Henry
showed up as a composer
um his influence actually made me cut a
lot of my lines out of the movie because
I was like oh I know that we can lean on
this the music That's How basically act
three of this film so man when you look
at all the dialogue in act three it's
maybe two or three pages of dialogue
it's mainly pushed by his amazing score
and like the amazing like uh shots that
our animators and layout artists were
able to pull off I love hearing about
the level of collaboration on this film
and it's something I had watched a
couple of interviews with your voice
cast here and it's something that they
had emphasized and you know this
question might be coming from me not
really knowing the specifics about what
goes on behind closed doors but it feels
like I hear more and more nowadays about
voice actors getting to play and
experiment in the booth and then the
animation adapting to what they're doing
is there anything about the filmmaking
process that has kind of changed in
recent years to accommodate that more
um I don't know if it's the process
itself to me it's more you know just uh
and directorily how you approach working
with your your cast I mean it's always
been kind of
um that's just been part of the way I've
worked and and and was taught to work
you know that you know we work these
scenes we write these scenes and
storyboard the scenes and get them
perfect you know and then we go in the
room and we record them but you know
that a lot so many times the actor will
do something that you want to respond to
in uh in the booth you know and and and
it's sometimes it can mean rewriting a
scene like Jake got uh had a question
about a scene that led to a conversation
that led to query writing the scene that
night and re-recorded it the next day
and I think for us it's just a natural
extension of of what we do every day
with with our Artist as we kind of
mentioned and how how we collaborated to
to make this film uh the voice cast
being no different it's just it I think
that this is an ultimately a massively
collaborative art form when it's at its
best so it definitely is a youth thing
and as I just said that and I was
hearing your answer I'm like oh well I
have covered this in Raya in a really
short span of time yeah yeah it was just
last year when we did wrong
it's worth it I promise you that um I'll
warn you I'm gonna end with a little bit
of a heavy question here but given the
emphasis that this film places on how
each new generation can influence the
world that we're in I'm gonna kind of
like turn that in towards this industry
can you each name someone who is like
rising in animation right now that you
think has the power to change that
corner of the film industry for the
better
oh that's that's a wow question
um
and like an individual like a group of
people anyone newer that we might not
know their names yet but there's
something special and we should be
keeping an eye out for them right now
well okay I I always go with whatever
pops in my head first I feel like and so
uh the name that popped in my head first
uh is Tyree Jones who is a a storyboard
artist
and new new to Disney I think this was
the first his first film
well certainly his first Disney film it
might have been this first film he's
worked on
um and you know uh so you know I had
never worked with Tyree before but it
was so amazing to work with him and he
had he not just in in terms of his
storyboarding but in terms of his
um you know just story skills in general
um you know he really collaborated in
the room and he storyboarded one of my
favorite scenes in the film which is the
uh when Jaeger and Searcher are having
um having a a beverage on a deck of the
Venture after uh you know Searcher is
taught to throw
um and and just Tyree made some
wonderful choices in there so that was
the first name
likewise like I think of our history
David Derek who uh you know has worked
with us throughout trying making helping
us make this film he was influential in
Moana and now he's directing Moana uh on
Disney plus the series that's about to
come out and to see his Evolution from
story artists uh to to a director has
been just you know in my short four
years at the studio has been just a gift
to see someone just grow and evolve and
and now is going to lead a team on all
his own to to something that I think is
going to be super entertaining and it
brings back to the world that obviously
Don worked on uh that we all care about
I love to hear it I'm going to be
keeping an eye out for them and also
telling everybody about strange world
it's delightful it's beautiful
congratulations to you both yet again
thank you so much we really appreciate
it